john and ccsd students head back to
school in a couple of weeks
while you may be shopping for supplies
you also may be considering
their health bianca holman is live with
back to school
dental care to tell us more about it hey
there bianca
hey good morning hector so yeah we're
here at union village kids dental care
and we're talking about all back to
school health so i'm joined here by dr
tucker so
getting our kids ready for the school
year how do you find a pediatric dentist
so when you're looking for a dentist for
your child especially a young child i
would highly recommend finding a
pediatric dentist
that's because we're trained to manage
children of all ages children that may
not be fully cooperative or may have any
growth or development issues
we handle all of that so it's a really
good thing to do yeah
and also again getting back to school
getting these teeth nice and pearly
white for their ready for school and
everything like that tell us why
dental care is so important before the
start of school so it's really important
because untreated issues that may cause
pain they can affect the child's sleep
they can affect attention span in school
and that may affect in behavior changes
or problems with attention span
and just poor performance yeah so we do
have a model here
donovan good morning donovan hey so
you're going to show us dr tucker
flossing it's so important i know even
as an adult we sometimes get frustrated
with flossing what are some tips that
you have
so when you're flossing for your child
sometimes it's a little difficult to use
the string floss so
we recommend the little floss picks and
those are really easy to use
because you can just gently go back and
forth can you open for me donovan good
job
can go back and forth between the teeth
and that just makes it easy kind of
keeps your fingers out of the mouth to
avoid any problems there
and then if your child is a little more
cooperative and you
are a little more bold you can go ahead
with the string floss which is a little
more effective
what we like to do is just tie a little
knot in it like that
what that does is it just catches any
debris that's stuck between the teeth
and then you just gently drag that knot
through the teeth and that really helps
clear in between them and that can help
keep your smile nice and healthy
all right perfect i swear dr tucker if i
had you as a dentist growing up i
probably wouldn't have those cavities
all right i know donovan is probably
gonna have great teeth as well so again
all great tips we got some more coming
up in the next half hour as we talk
about dental care
as our kids head back to school back to
you guys in the studio